automation anywhere is one of the
leading robotic process automation
platforms
automation anywhere is built on the
world's most commonly used automation
and artificial intelligence platform hey
everyone
i welcome you all to this session in
this session we will learn about
automation anywhere tutorial
let's look at today's agenda we shall
begin with
understanding what is automation
anywhere
then we will look at the key features of
automation anywhere
proceeding further we will see the
different components of
automation anywhere followed by which we
will understand the architecture of
automation anywhere
further we will see the different types
of bots
and look at the key benefits of
automation anywhere
finally we will look at hands-on
demonstration
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel
and clicked on the bell icon so you
never miss an update from simply learn
so without wasting any further time
let's get started with the tutorial on
automation anywhere
what is automation anywhere
automation anywhere is a well known
robotic process automation tool
that enables business to automate
end-to-end business operations
automation anywhere provides powerful
and user-friendly rba capabilities
such as cloud native web-based
intelligent automation
solution for automating any complex task
it is a web-based management system that
employs a control room to execute
automated tasks it improves the
efficiency of business process
and reduces the need for human labor
features of automation anywhere
automation anywhere offers an easy to
use interface
for building bots and designing business
process automation workflows
it supports multiple operating system
such as windows
linux and mac os
it consists of a recorder that works on
a variety of platforms including
microsoft windows
citrix web and sap
it consists of different bot views for
collaboration
flow view for business users list view
for developers
and dual view for collaboration
automation anywhere supports platforms
like
javascript python and vbscript
as well as advanced variable
capabilities
another key feature is its versatile
architecture
that allows for the addition of new
command packages
let's look at the automation anywhere
components
the first component is automation
anywhere robotic interface
aari it is a user-friendly interface
that allows business users to
collaborate with bots
users can initiate process automation
provide feedback to the bots in order
for process to be resumed
and escalate requests to additional
users for downstream processing
aari that is automation anywhere robotic
interface
enables enterprises to unlock previously
unavailable
automation opportunities between humans
and the bots
iqbot an intelligent document processing
solution
capable of reading and processing a wide
range of complex documents and emails
iqbot intelligently captures classifies
and extracts semi-structured
and unstructured data using rpa and
multiple ai
techniques allowing document centric
business process to be automated end to
end
what inside the analytics platform that
delivers real-time
interactive and intelligent insights
into business process
and operational intelligence bot insight
takes a large amount of content level
and productivity data generated by
deployed bots
and converts it into insights via
automatically generated
and customizable dashboards
discovery bot an intelligent business
solution for enterprise business
that enables end users to discover
automation opportunities
through process discovery discovery
board focuses on process automation
by capturing document process
identifying opportunities from business
centric process
and pre-authorizing opportunities based
on roi
and create bots automatically discovery
bot
collaborates with business workers to
identify automation opportunities
that can maximize the return on your rpa
investment
let's look at the architecture of
automation anywhere
automation anywhere platform is built
using a distributed architecture
the enterprise control room a web-based
platform
that manages the development and
execution of digital workforce
provides centralized management bot
creators and bot runners
are linked to the enterprise control
room bot creators
are software development platforms for
authorizing
and customizing automations bot runners
are runtime system deployed on the
machine that carry out the automations
bot runners can be installed on desktops
in data centers or in the cloud
let's explore the architecture in detail
what creators a bot is a self-contained
task that requires little to no human
intervention to complete
the bot creator is a customized
development client for automation
anywhere that is used to create
bots task editor event watcher
bot player auto login and local
scheduler
are all included the bot creator
also includes the ability to create
boards from a device
utilizing the enterprise client
application
the device is registered with the
enterprise control room
after the bot creator user signs in for
the first time
and the user can deploy bots on that
device
bought runners a bot trainer has the
ability to run bots
from a device utilizing the enterprise
client application
the device is registered with the
enterprise control room
after the bot runner users log in for
the first time
and the user can deploy bots on that
device
ports are run by the bot runner which is
a software machine
bot runners can run bots at scale after
they have been developed
with bot create
control room the enterprise control room
serves as a single point of management
for all bots
enterprise control room is placed on a
server in the data
center and configured to work with the
other data center components
a river proxy is in charge of listening
for request
for remote connections and sending them
to the appropriate specialized service
using a collection of specialized web
service
the enterprise control room manages
schedules
executes and configures various bots
and bot runner capabilities
let's look at the types of bots in
automation anywhere
task bot task bots are used for
automating repetitive tasks
based on the rules these tasks are
simple to create
and can reliably complete multi-step
procedures
document administration claims
management
hr departments i.t and other areas
benefit from task bots
they increase production reduce errors
and save money
metabot metabots are more advanced
version
of task bots metabots are automation
building components
that help with next generation
integration scalability
these are intended for scalable complex
process
on a computer metabots are used to
automate applications
application apis visual captures
and integration flow can all be used to
develop meta bots
iqbot iq bots are the next generation of
intelligent bots
with the ability to think like humans
these bots
are designed to learn on their own and
carry out tasks
in accordance with that learning users
can experience the potential of
automation with iq bots
which use advanced cognitive technology
and advanced artificial technologies
these bots
have capabilities such as self-learning
decision making
and subject matter expertise among
others
data can be extracted from
semi-structured and unstructured data
by these bots iq bots also learn to
recognize patterns
so that the bot knows exactly what to do
the next time the pattern appears
iq bots also learn to recognize patterns
so that the bot knows exactly what to do
the next time the pattern appears
with each human confirmation it learns
and improves its ability to carry out
the act benefits of using automation
anywhere
time saving an easy to use interface
that allows users
of varying skill levels to easily use
the product
and accelerate the learning process with
instant web-based deployment
you can get started with writing bots
right away
business adaptability automation
anywhere provides regular updates
ensuring that you are always up to date
on any device
anywhere it provides continuity of
operations
with high availability and disaster
recovery
low cost of ownership there is no need
for additional infrastructure investment
it gives low cost maintenance a unified
platform for front office
back office and employee applications is
provided
let's look at the demo so let's see a
demo
in this demo we'll create a bot which
will automatically
login inside the simply learn login page
so i'll show you
let's go to the browser i'll go to the
simply learns
page
so this is the simply launch login page
so in this page the bot will
automatically enter the email address
password and it will click on the login
button
and it will take you inside the simply
lens page
so we'll create a bot so
i'll show you how the bot works so i
have created it
let's see the output first and then
we'll get started with the
project so i'll click on the run button
it will download all the dependencies
here you can see it's entering the email
address
it's entering the password and it will
click on the login button
so this is the project this is the
output
so you have seen the output so let's get
started
we'll close this go to the go to the
mail which you received from the
automation anywhere and click on the
control room link
and you will open up here after coming
here
click on create a bot
so enter a name
let's say we'll enter as login bot
since we are creating a
project to login if you want you can
give the description
and next click on create and edit
there are three options here flow list
and dual
in the flow it only shows the flowchart
of what activities or actions
you are dragging and dropping it in the
list it shows the in the form of the
list
all the actions and in the dual it shows
the flowchart
as well as the actions what actions it
is performing
so first we need the browser option so
we'll search for the browser action
so this is the browser action so the
browser package
contains actions that enable you to
download file find broken lines
and launch a website so this package
basically supports internet explorer
microsoft edge and google chrome
browsers
so the browser package includes the
actions like close
download file get source code find
broken lines go back
open run javascript now for us to
open the browser to open the simply
learns website
we need the open option so let's click
on the
open double click on the open
so what open does is opens the browser
to a specific web page
whichever webpage link we provides it
opens that browser so
what we want to open do we want to open
it in the existing tab
or a new tab or a new window so in
existing tab
it opens the web page in the currently
open tab
so this existing tab option is only
available in the google chrome browser
and new tab opens the web page in a new
tab like select the tab from the list of
the active tabs in the google chrome
browser or insert a new window variable
and in the new window this opens a
webpage in the new window or
office specific browser whichever
browser you choose it opens a web page
in a new window
so all these options are applicable in
the google chrome
browser so we will select the new window
option
and the browser okay you have these
options
internet explorer mozilla firefox chrome
and microsoft edge
so we will select google chrome and
we'll select the link to open
so we should select the link so
we'll go to the simplylands website page
so this is the page we are logging in so
that is why we need the
link of this page so copy the link of
this page
and paste the link here
and we need it in the new window so
save it
and let's run and see if this opens
in the new window let's click on run
okay so till now we are going right so
we have
entered the link and we have run the bot
and the bot is opening the
webpage in the new window so we'll close
this
so after this we need the recorder
package
so search for the recorder package
so this is the recorder package in this
we have the capture
action so the capture action from the
recorder package
is used to capture an interaction with
the user interface object
such as a text box button table menu
radio button combo box check box list
view link
tree and package tab the capture action
enables you to add single interaction
when building your bot
so let's double click on capture option
so let's select dual so that we can see
what action it
triggers
so after selecting the capture option
so select the browser option browser
window then
click on this refresh windows
so it will show a list of uh
so it will show the list of pages that
are open in the browser
so scroll down and we need learning on
simply
so this is the web page in which we are
logging in
so select the web page
go down and let's click on capture
object
click on capture object so first we need
to fill in the email address
so you can see here it's showing a red
color box
so click on email address
so it will capture this object of email
address here you can see
recording capture finalization
so the object is captured scroll down
and here you can see action to take on
object what action should be taken on
the object which we have selected
so we need to enter the text
that is the email address so select set
text
and scroll down and enter
what text you want to enter that
so i'll enter my email id
now scroll down
you can enter the time how much ever you
want
it is recommended to enter a 9 seconds
or 10 seconds
but it's optional so we'll skip it for
now
you can see here it's the object type
user login
page so we have
captured the first object that is email
address
so we'll save it
and we'll run and see if it's entering
the email address
here you can see it's open the web page
in the new window
and it has entered the email address
so let's go back to the control room
close this
your bot has run successfully so now
that we have
entered the email address we need to
enter the password
so we will use another capture
action
and this will will select the same
browser window
and will select the same
learning on simply done website
and we'll click on capture object but
now this time we'll capture the object
password select the password
object and recording capture
finalization
so now that the object is captured we
need to
select the action what action should be
performed
so we will select set text
now that we have selected text since we
are entering the password
the password should be credential and
when the password is credentialed you
can't
enter the password here you need to pick
the password
you need to pick the password from the
locker room
so now that now that i have already
created a credential and
entered in the locker room for me it's
showing here i'll show you
how to create a credential and create a
locker room so we'll save it till here
for now
we'll save here
let's go to the credentials section here
if you go
in the manage options you can see
credentials
so go in the credentials
this is the credentials which i have
already created
go to the create credential options
click on it
so enter the credential name
say i'll enter it as username
enter the description if you want any
and scroll down
and enter the attribute name what
attribute are you entering
for first we will enter the email
address
so select
email address and
select the input type as standard
description is optional
and enter the value what is the email
address so i'll enter my email address
scroll down and click on the plus here
to add so there are two attributes in
the login page right
that is the email address and password
so one attribute we have entered the
email address
and the other attribute is the password
attribute
so select password and input type as
standard
and since we are entering the password
it should be masked
so that no one could see your password
the password should
be encrypted so enter your password here
after entering the password
so you have created the you have filled
all the credential details
click on create credential so after
clicking on create credential
your credential will be created
so that is how you create a credential
after creating the credential
so since i have already created a
credential i'll
click on cancel before creating
if you want to create the credential
enter all these details and click on the
create page
so i'll click on cancel so this is once
you create the credential you can see
like this a credential whatever you have
created it will be shown here
so this is how you create a credential
now after creating
the credential you need to go to the
locker section
and here you can see create a locker
click on create a locker
so enter the locker room whatever you
want
so let us enter username
after entering the locker room go to the
credential
and select the credential whatever you
have created
since i have already entered the
credential in the locker
that is why it is that is why this is
disabled for me
so when you are entering the credential
in the locker room for the first time
can come inside the locker and select
this option check this option
and click on this so this will get
this will get deposited in the locker
this owners and managers
section is disabled the community
edition
so we can't do any changes in that this
will also be disabled
this will also be disabled go to the
consumers
so enable this enable this click on the
community edition user and
get deposit this in the locker click on
this
then scroll down so this is the last
then when you go back scroll up when you
finish doing all this
this create locker option will get
enabled
so when this option get enabled click on
create locker and your locker will be
created
that's how you create a blocker since i
have already created a locker
i did not so this options are not
enabled for me
so this option is also not enabled when
you do all these steps
this option gets enabled that is how you
create a locker
i hope you have understood how to create
a credential and
how to create a locker so let's go back
to the bot which we had created let's go
to the automation
so the bot which we had created was a
login bot
so we had selected the recorder option
in this recorder we had selected the
action
password so we need to enter the
password
so select here go to here
click on pick and select the locker
which we had created
the email address
select the credential that is the email
address credential
select the attribute attribute is the
password attribute we had entered two
attributes right one is the email
address and the password
so we are entering the password here
select the
password attribute and click on confirm
scroll down
here you can see we have picked the
password
if you want you can enter the time which
is optional
you can see it is of the type user
password
so that's all save it now we need a
one more recorder action that is to
click on the
login button so we'll select for the
search for the recorder select the
capture option
and we'll select the browser
select the web page and click on the
capture object
so the object which we are capturing now
is the
login button so click on the login
button
here you can see recording capture
finalization
so the login button is been captured so
what action should be
taken
so we need to click on the login button
here you can
see if you have noticed there is no
option to set text
why because this is a login button when
we can't enter the text here so that
option is
not here so from this options
we should select the click option to
login so
we'll select the click option
and you can see here it is of the type
login
button login so we have selected the
login button
now we'll save it
so we have completed the project in the
first step we have selected the browser
package
in browser package we have selected the
open action
which opens the web page the link page
we have provided it opens a webpage
in the second we have selected from the
recorder package we have selected the
capture option
in which we have captured the email
address then we have captured the
password
and then we have captured to click on
the login button
so let's save it we have saved it so
let's click on
run and see
here you can see the webpage has opened
in the new window
email address has been entered
password has been entered and it is
clicking on the login page
and it is redirecting to the website
and here you can see the login but login
page has been
open so your what has run successfully
if you have any doubts and any queries
or
related to the demo or the automation
anywhere tutorial
please ask in the comment section we'll
try to answer all your possible
questions
so with that we have reached the end of
this video like and share it if you
found it interesting
thank you for being here keep learning
and stay tuned to simply
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here